In this video we'll show you the basics of creating users in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition
and show you how to set up role-based access control.
If you select team from the top navigation menu you can see a list of all the users,
groups and roles that have already been configured. A user can be a person who needs to log into the
web interface or you can create API users that other machines or applications can use to interact
with Burp Suite Enterprise Edition. As you can see here I've got one for my Jenkins integration for
example. We'll look at API users and integrating with CI-CD in a separate video. A role is just a
collection of actions that you're allowed to perform. There are several built-in roles that
you start out with so if we look at the scan initiator role for example this has access to
view scans, sites, issue details and edit the schedule of a scan and so on.
A group is essentially just a mapping of users to roles. So as you can see here there's a built-in
group that corresponds to each of the roles we just saw. Each of these groups has that role assigned to
it as well as a few users. As user management in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition is based on the role-based
access control model you don't assign permissions directly to individual users. Instead you create
roles that represent different types of user and then assign those to a group. Users then inherit all
of the permissions from whichever groups they belong to. This is a lot simpler than it sounds once you see
it in practice so let's walk through an example together. First of all I'm going to create a new role
and call it scan reviewer.
Now I just need to select all of the things that I want people with this role to be able to do.
As you can see these permissions are grouped based on the objects that the actions relate to like sites
or scans for example. You might not be able to see this in the video very well but if you look closely
you can see that some of these permissions are greyed out. This is because they're dependent on
another permission being granted first. So for example most of the scan related permissions are
greyed out here because obviously it doesn't make much sense to be able to delete scans unless you can
view them in the first place. So once we select the view scans role some of these other scan related
permissions will become available. You might find it easier to select all of the permissions in a
folder and then just deselect the ones you don't want. I'll quickly just set the rest of the permissions
that I want for this role. When you're done just click save and you can see that the new role now appears
alongside the built-in ones. So next I'll create a corresponding group
and we'll call it scan reviewers US. I'll show you why in a second.
Now we can assign the role that we just created to this group. Note that you can actually assign
multiple different roles to a group but we don't need to do that for this example.
And now I'll just assign some of the existing users to this group.
Finally you can apply site restrictions for a group. So by default the members of a group will
be able to perform all of their permitted actions on all of the sites that you have configured.
So you can choose to limit them so that they're only allowed to interact with specific sites.
Just like with the permissions you can select these individually or just select the entire folder
and exclude specific sites if that's easier. For this example I'll let members of this group work
with all US-based sites only. And now we're done so I can go ahead and save the group.
So we've already added some existing users to this group but let's create a new one as well.
As you've probably already guessed you can do this by going to the users tab and then just clicking
new user. Or alternatively you can hover over the team menu here and just select add a new user.
You'll then be asked to enter some basic user details.
If this is just a normal user that needs to log into the Burpsuite Enterprise Edition web interface
just leave the login type set to password. If you were creating an API user you'd select API key here
obviously but we'll save that for another time. Then just assign them to any relevant groups.
When you go to save you'll be prompted to copy a password generation link and send this to the user
so that they can set up their initial password. If your admin user happens to have also configured
a connection to an SMTP server already then the user will also receive an email containing this link.
Finally I just want to point out that Burpsuite Enterprise Edition also supports single sign-on
using LDAP or SAML but we'll cover this in more detail in a separate video.
So that's how to get started with user management and role-based access control in Burpsuite Enterprise Edition.
So that's how to get started with user management.